la mode est un art et la couture
française compte parmi les grandes
traditions culturelles et économiques de
notre pays
le ministre de la culture jack lang l'a
rappelé en inaugurant avec madame
mitterrand la semaine du prêt-à-porter
et si vous vous en doutez rendez vous
ces jours ci au louvre car les courts du
louvre abrite jusqu'au 31 mars
les défilés de mode le spectacle vaut le
coup d'oeil france roche news y entraîne
la culture est venu rendre visite au roi
le périssable
alain périssables dans la cour carrée du
louvre qui vit les balles royaux
l'arrivée des vénus grecque
on avait connu en fait d'art moderne
qu'à celui des balles voici qui défilent
d'autres chorégraphies celle des
collections des créateurs de prêt à
porter le plastique le ciré le cachemire
de lanvin la roche ou cheyrou ti ont
remplacé les dorures et l'esata mais ce
fou et se valaient sortie d'un jeu de
cartes géants imaginé par un couturier
japonais qui me dumas est tout à fait
dans la notice toriques
sous les tentes où l'on montre six
collections par jour les bêtes de mode
internationale on vous surgir de
blizzard marquis perruque et tenant à la
fois du carnaval de venise et des
plaideurs ou bien des mégères sorti tout
droit des tavernes shakespearienne et
attendent dans falstaff des bonnets de
pierrot sur la tête ça c'était pour
l'hommage à l'histoire mais il y à aussi
la mode d'aujourd'hui qui est je vous
l'annonçais tout de suite conquise par
le style pin qu'on passera du théâtre à
la poubelle les mannequins n'ont jamais
été très très souriante mais cette fois
ci elle cherche visiblement à mordre
pour être bien il faudra être trop trop
long et court trop large trop usé trop
clinquant trop serrer trop colorés ou
trop loin on ira du bal des vampires à
la fête foraine du cirque au bric-à-brac
d'une grogne air points à l'asile de
l'est rapiéçage feront bon ménage avec
les paillettes mais ce n'est pas tout à
fait le style de mal à mitterrand venu
inaugurer avec le ministre de la culture
s'est défilé
maria
la mode n'est pas un parent pauvre la
création artistique
elle est au contraire un art à part
entière qui comme tel doit être
pleinement reconnue qui dans notre pays
dans nos institutions doivent avoir
plein droit de cité sous l'autorité de
monsieur le ministre de l'industrie un
plan de soutien à l'industrie textile et
de l'habillement a été élaboré ce plan
est destiné à mieux nous armer mieux
vous armé pour faire face à la
concurrence internationale est destiné à
mieux les armer mieux vous armer pour
assurer aux entreprises leur plat des
bleus il a annoncé enfin la création 83
d'un musée du costume ou seront
conservés les plus belles robes de notre
temps les pirouettes seront saisis enfin
par l'histoire